- Even outside of quantum computers,
some of the theories that
we've been talking about,
what's your hope,
what's most promising
to test these theories?
What are kind of
experiments we can conduct,
whether in simulation or
in the physical world,
that would validate or disprove
or expand these theories?
- Well I think for,
there's two parts of that question.
One is many-worlds
and the other one is sort
of emergent spacetime.
For many-worlds, you know
there are experiments ongoing
to test whether or not wave
functions spontaneously collapse
and if they do then that
rules out many-worlds
and that will be falsified.
What if there are hidden variables?
There's a theorem that seems to indicate
that the predictions will always
be the same as many-worlds.
I'm a little skeptical of this
theorem, I'm not completely,
I haven't internalized it,
I haven't made it in
part of my intuitive view
of the world yet,
so there might be
loopholes to that theorem,
I'm not sure about that.
Part of me thinks that
there should be different
experimental predictions
if there are hidden variables,
but I'm not sure.
But otherwise, it's just quantum
mechanics all the way down
and so there's this cottage
industry in science journalism
of writing breathless articles that say,
"quantum mechanics shown
to be more astonishing
than ever before thought"
and really it's the same quantum mechanics
we've been doing since 1926.
Whereas with the emergent spacetime stuff,
we know a lot less about
what the theory is.
It's in a very primitive state.
We don't even really have
a safely written down,
respectable, honest theory yet,
so there could very well
be experimental predictions
we just don't know about yet.
That is one of the things that
we're trying to figure out.
- But for emergent spacetime,
you need really big stuff, right?
- Well, or really fast stuff
or really energetic stuff,
we don't know, that's the thing.
You know, so there could be
violations of the speed of light
if you have emergent spacetime.
Not going faster than the speed of light,
but the speed of light could be different
for light of different wavelengths, right?
That'll be a dramatic violation
of physics as we know it
but it could be possible.
Or not, I mean it's not
an absolute prediction,
that's the problem.
The theories are just not well
developed enough yet to say.